[Music]
[Music]
hello
hello dominic hello face how's it going
i'm doing pretty well how are you i'm
pretty good you got an itchy eye i like
itching my eye
if you
if you could uh say which you get more
pleasure out of itching your eye
deep in your nose or deep in your ear do
you have a
an answer i would think if that i had a
niche a real itch in one of them
yeah i see that uh if if um if i had a
real etch i would say probably my eye i
used to itch my eyes a lot when i was
younger and my gran used to say i
probably got diabetes
strange
what's that going to do with itching
your eye i'm
guessing you your gran wasn't a nurse or
a doctor right well she she used to um
she was a midwife during the war
and would but not in any trained way
right she just pulled babies out before
the night
before the national health service or
anything and people couldn't afford to
go to the hospital
my gran would go and deliver their
babies well good for her
i don't think her knowledge of diabetes
was very so you as a kid you beat school
and she goes that's you in a diabetes
thing yeah
you better watch that she'd say
well i don't i don't know if that's true
right guys i'm going to tell you what
i've been doing this week and i've spent
a lot of time doing this and i love it
it's a new
game and it's my new favorite mobile
puzzle game and it's called
best fiends oh yes
i think you'll like it you probably
played games like this before but this
one's better it's got a story
it's got these little fiends these guys
that help you on your adventure
they're just little like baby fiends but
the more you play the bigger they get
and more of them to help you against the
slugs who are the bad guys anyway i've
spent a lot of time playing this and
it's fantastic
download best fiends free today on the
app store or google play that's friends
without the r best fiends
do you sometimes i sometimes get an itch
in my ear that you can't scratch which
is really maddening
don't put don't put a thing in no
what's the thing called well in in the
united states they call them q-tips
right but like cotton cotton buds on a
stick type don't stick it right in the
doctors say which is very strange don't
put anything smaller than your elbow in
your ear which is weird because your
elbow is massive huge that thing the the
cotton
q-tip for the american people out there
that is only supposed to clean the
exterior of your ears so all these
little channels i have a lot of them
because my ears are massive
they're nice but not thanks but not to
go in but around the the around the
entrance maybe around the edges
no you know you shouldn't dig in because
more than anything else you're digging
it in so as i've done eyes ears now nose
do you use uh
a netty pot for cleaning out your nose
at any time no but i have one that's
similar which uh the neti pot is more of
a pour
and let gravity do its thing i have one
that fires it up under pressure yeah so
you go
and it goes up and then out and that's
really turned my sinuses around and you
need that in los angeles because i think
uh los angeles really
cries havoc on your uh your inners in
there yeah yeah my sinuses really took a
downward turn when it came to la but
that thing has really helped you and i
both are quite
um
diligent with our nasal hair aren't we
well i have to be because it is an
absolute outrage and i don't know this
isn't actually an ad but manscape do a
nose hair trimmer i do which i'm using
and it works a treat because sometimes
those things don't work too good yeah
this one watch the tree it's awful and
they don't work too good because what it
sometimes can do is it can slow down
when it's up there so you go
and then it gets stuck and you're like
oh god try and change the battery while
it's up there uh which can be announced
anybody got a couple of double a's but
your nose is clean as a whistle right
now it's not too bad and i also get this
one singular hair yeah tell them about
that the unicorn hair i call it that
grows right on the end of my nose here
and it won't be there
for like a month two months and then
literally
overnight
there's a hair
that is an
inch long
right on the end of my nose yeah i
remember you showing it to me when we
were doing a press tour once for lord of
the rings you'll be like look at this
thing yeah and then from then in the 15
20 years since then
i've seen it a couple of times in in
profile i've been like oh it's back
bill's back and you've asked your wife
to keep an eye on it i'm here i'll pluck
it yeah it's a good idea
my dad subscribes to the idea it seems
of well no that's my nose hair is the
reason why it's there so i'm just going
to let it grow i'm like dad
just even if you just
because my mom and i are always like
come on even if you just follow the
contours of your nose austin yeah like i
get that you might want some nasal hairs
up there to stop you know pigeons flying
up there but you don't want it to be 3d
my dad almost has like a nasal beard no
yeah
because your dad is a good-looking man
he's a very handsome man but
things like that can really take you
down yeah good couple of marks the great
thing about my dad which you have a
little bit of this energy my dad's like
what does it matter do you know what i
mean it doesn't
why should it concern you it doesn't
concern me and i love that energy but
you're just like well like you said
you're a handsome man dad you don't need
that yeah and i can tell with my mum
she's like oh austin don't just get rid
of it so when i show up because i i
don't see them anywhere near as much as
my mom sees my dad
and i say those things my mom was like
yeah cool yeah
you get him to do tell us interesting
about my dad
more than anyone else i've ever met my
dad gets
confused for a lot of people
even by me
i'll tell you a few people now right ian
the late and beautiful ian holm i've saw
that happening he was confused by you
saw that happen at premieres your wife
thought that he was ian holmes well for
quite a while yeah yep
george bush
junior see that is that because he's
bushing noise here no he's just i wrote
this down actually i wrote down wrote
down in my in my phone at one point
people who my dad gets confused for
because i thought it was interesting um
the george bush junior not the um
senior not senior because he's you know
he doesn't quite look like that hang on
we're scrolling down here we're
scrolling down talking about your sales
bills um there was someone else that i
used to think he looked like yeah
there's a lot he might be in this list
here you go here you go the late great
ian holm
yep george bush
nah no no when he's younger not now as
much but when he's younger paul simon
no no no no no no no robin williams i'll
give you that yeah yeah nowadays
although not when he was younger but
nowadays anthony hopkins anthony hogg
they have they have a little anthony
hockens thing yeah
and this is a bit obtuse and it's not
necessarily that he looks like him but
sometimes my dad does things like jose
mourinho
oh really just a couple of looks and a
couple of ways that he kind of side eyes
you i'm like oh you've got any jose
mourinho
no i can see that as well yeah
[Music]
anyway he's interested in your dad we
had asked people on instagram
if they had any burning questions
to ask you yes why not ask me yeah and
you did
the the exact opposite of that does
anyone have a question
they would like me to ask don monaghan i
thought maybe we could do like a
lightning round right where we just
scroll through it and we try and get
through as many of these questions as
possible right so
go to your story a minute
go to the little
that a minute
little thing there i'm gonna i'm gonna
um put on my glasses stop to make this
easier yeah put on your on your glasses
hey hold on
then i've got to go to here and then
ah wrong one oh wait a minute
what
is it gone
oh is it gone is yours run out yeah
well that's a shame is that does that
mean it's just gone gone
should we do it next time how come
because yours were you you it's on a
timer it lasts for about but you put
mine up before before i put yours up
let's see if mine's gone all right
mine's gone
because i have written down ones for you
oh can we just do it one way well i'd
remember a couple of the ones that stood
out for me
so i can just say them all right
how many questions have you got so this
hasn't worked out exactly as we wanted
ladies and gentlemen we'll try this
again at another time but we'll do a
quick lightening
of why don't i just do me to you as soon
as i've written them down
one two
three four five six seven eight nine
there's about ten or eleven okay i
remember two that they've asked you
ready lightning round go on right this
is from ri
fi kamaka
great
i actually sent you two okay ready
do you like mount a python love money
python well that's good favorite sketch
quickly
um probably the argument sketch oh yes
yeah love it okay
what was the film that most wanted you
to become made you want to become an
actor
probably in past tracks back very good
on the set of lauder rings did you have
a favorite spot where you wanted to just
chill out and be alone
my trailer and the trailer okay
do all cap oh that was from bohemian
jean by the way now this one is from
eloise
c 1991
do all caterpillars become butterflies
or moths
yeah
well there you go that's a good answer
well done
kiki that uh
degrade
tardigrade tardigrade that's the little
uh tiny little animal that you can fire
into space and boiling water and put in
frozen ice and it'll stay alive right
well kiki the tardigrade says how do you
say lettuce backwards
perfect well done dom good question
what do you keep on your bedside table
says kaylee danielle uh lots of books
lots of books probably
ten no eight books um
charging for my phone
uh always a bo i always have this when i
go to sleep bottle of water very good
hydration get this from my mum i take a
massive cup of water just before i go to
sleep and usually at some point in the
middle of the night i'll wake up and
drink more water
i'll give you another three dom from
braun storm five what's a tv show that
you watch that no one would have
expected you to have watched
we talked about survivor before so i
think people know that i watch survivor
massive fan of the larry sanders show as
well
not around anymore but well worth
checking out
aaron prime aaronprime01 says
if you could be an animal for just one
day
what animal would you be and why okay
well i am an animal that's worth just
pointing out that's true yeah another
animal we'll see thank you give me
another animal for just one day what
would it be and why probably an elephant
just to feel that power
if it's just for a day no it's just a
day that's exactly well i just want to
know what it feels like to have that
strength that strength amazing i saw an
elephant the other day online kick a
crocodile to death my god that's hectic
would you do that if you no no no no
just kick it once just just to feel
about see your heart and i can hurl it
you know
amazing but you wouldn't want to be like
a peregrine falcon secretary i mean
there's so many things like a whale
would be amazing as well but i just you
can only choose the lightning round all
right you're only one more dom
wait a minute oh cjj
one
what is your favorite lord of the rings
weapon
private lord weapon from the lord of the
rings your favorites
probably
gandalf sword
is that glam drink i don't know the name
of it we'd need to ask stephen colbert
john he knows all about the rings
he's amazing um
amazing i've got two questions that when
i looked at my stuff i was like oh i'll
definitely ask those two questions
because they were great
um
actually three questions oh let's added
one don't know who they're from favorite
scottish film
gregory's girl definitely knew it'd be
that favorite thing about being scottish
um
it feels like being part of a a little
uh
club that not a lot of people are part
of but
other people in bigger clubs like
america australians seem to like that
little club no nice no that's a great
answer
well as you guys out there know i have
been given the nickname mr generous head
from all of my friends because i do give
the greatest gift if billy were to ask
me to move into my house and kick me out
on the street i'd say yeah you can have
it that's fine because i'll just give
people whatever they want but if you're
struggling this holiday season for
something to buy that extra special
someone might i suggest ball and branch
cheats the gift everyone wants for a
better night's sleep bowling branch
never disappoints with the highest
quality sheets blankets pillows and
throws plus their holiday packaging
makes your gift look and feel special
i tell you what dom i really like this
company and you know how it started it
was a couple they couldn't find good
quality sheets at a good price so they
started their own company and they are
fantastic i've been using them for years
actually and i think they're the best
sheets that i have slept on some other
sheets the more you wash them they get
they're not as comfortable as they were
these get better as you wash them down
they are fantastic yes they are
signature hemmed sheets and they are an
all-time bestseller they're beloved for
many reasons like how they get softer as
you said with every wash they're
completely toxin free and fair trade
certified
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the new standard embedding from ballen
branch their gifts come wrapped and
ready in their special holiday packaging
order by 19th of december for guaranteed
delivery by christmas
best deals of the year going on now from
the 1st of november to the 11th of
november with promo code onion at
ballenbranch.com
that's b-o-l-l and branch.com promo code
onion exclusions may apply
ho ho ho gentlemen the holidays came
early here at manscape the leading men's
hygiene brand manscape just launched new
products including their all-new ultra
premium body wash and a two-in-one
shampoo and conditioner it's time to
give yourself or someone who needs it
the gift of beautiful skin beautiful
hair and yes beautiful bowls this
holiday season go to manscape.com and
use the code onion for 20 off plus free
shipping
untrimmed pubic hair is really a thing
of the past tom but i know
um from my own experience sometimes it
can go astray but with a new trimmer
it's absolutely fantastic you can
virtually just trim away dom it's all
very very good
yes it's also waterproof so you can use
it in the shower it's like a gift to
your partner with less mess you know the
manscape performance package 4.0 also
includes the crop preserver and crop
reviver an anti-chafing ball deodorant
moisturizer and toner it's time to keep
your north pole feeling and smelling
breath
tis the season to load up on manscape
products so get yourself your dad your
brother
all your friends the best gift of all
the manscape performance package 4.0
get 20 off plus free shipping with a
good onion at manscape.com
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code onion manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use the code onion clean up your nuts
and make santa especially proud of you
this year
and then
oh what is something that you
do
or or no
that you
don't know that that i don't know about
you that you're like a secret thing
or like a hidden thing or something
where you're like i could tell you this
and it would surprise you
tell you wow that's a good one dumb
i mean because you know most like if i
said you know i can
i could bind a leather book you would
know that you know any music thing that
i said you would know that
that's why i liked it yeah i can't i
can't knit or something i'd like to tell
you that i could do that but i can't do
that i'm considering learning how to
crochet did you see tom daley i saw him
yeah that's what made me think of it
he's been crocheting a a jumper or a
blanket and also a little pouch for his
gold medal i thought that was cool while
he's watching and stuff i can't think of
something that i can do that you
wouldn't know about well yeah or just
something that i don't know well there
you go that's just shows we're great
friends i'm going to be thinking about
that across the whole show now why don't
you think about it
while we have a quiz
are we having a quiz
we're having a quiz it's quiz time
[Music]
oh do i love quizzes i'll bring people
on while we wait for it to bring people
oh there's sarah is it sarah or sarah
sarah sarah you know all of my british
friends asked me that yeah but it is
sarah but you can call me sarah if that
no no no please she'll tell you
do you know why british people ask you
that question sarah why do they it's
because
your way of spelling sarah does not have
an h
and most of the time uh that does it
yeah most of the time in britain we
spell sarah with an h don't we so is
anyone in the united states called sarah
not sure i don't think so i've never met
anyone who pronounces their name like
that right right okay so sarah because
that's what we do wouldn't we in britain
yeah if we saw someone spelled like that
we would call them sarah yeah yep
all right
sarah i will respond but
we'll do sarah hi miranda how are you hi
i'm great thanks for having me oh it's
lovely i'm so excited that you're here
well do we need to sing a song
we'll need to do the quest song hold on
and we're just gonna do the quiz song
do you know the answers to the questions
that we'll ask do you know the answers
do you know the answers to the questions
that will ask do you know the answers
will you
take the bling
we normally have a guitar there but i
think acapella's quite yeah we didn't
bring we didn't bring well it's quite
apropos yeah as it's very apropos these
days or at least we will make it a
proposal um so now we have to ask you
well there's a slight rule change ladies
which will tell the listeners and
viewers at home you probably already
know about this but we we do have to ask
you um
what is it will you
well you take the ring tomorrow is that
right
yes yeah will you take the ring
tomorrow yes yes that's what we'll do so
we're going to ask
uh sarah not sarah sarah and then serge
do you know you have to reply about do
you know where you are
uh sarah
will you take the ring to mordor
i will take the ring to mordor yes
but i don't know the way no the way
and then we've got miranda
miranda
will you take the ring to mordor
i will take it i will take the ring to
mordor
but do you
know way
this is where we find out if you do know
the way tomorrow door and the slight
adaptation to the quiz this week and i
think maybe even ongoing is that the
winner of this quiz
gets a chance to ask billy and i a
question and unfortunately the loser
just has to watch yeah that's an
absolute disgrace now
john our producer always lets us down
with the quiz he always gives us the
wrong answers etc as you probably know
if you listen to the friendship onion so
this time we have asked for questions
from listeners as well as from wonderful
producer john
so these first two questions dom yeah
were written by amy
c and she lives in a place called
location which makes me think she never
gave her location yeah that's very cool
wait wait wait we need to pick sides oh
yeah so why don't you do the finger
thing right you close your eyes and then
um
wait what did he do last night dad said
that you can't i close my eyes do you
give a number it's sarah a number
everything i have to say sarah no oh no
i'll say sarah and then i'll put myself
you go sarah and then
there all right all right close your
eyes i'm done okay sarah
miranda
okay
i would like on my team number one you
are team miranda grey miranda here we go
we're gonna win this all right here we
go
i will say before we begin
i think these questions are really quite
hard do you think we should start with
easier ones because there aren't easy
ones really no these they get hard and
hard as they go number three is an
outrage yeah just on you just on ego i
think right shall we just do it yeah go
on dumb oh okay okay okay so i'm asking
miranda yeah you're asking miranda
miranda question number one
the grey wizard uh was not always known
as gandalf
what was
the first name
of the grey wizard what was it is i'm
going to give you a multiple choice
was it
isn't
these are not easy i know would you have
no idea
i wouldn't have known that i would have
guessed a different one
i've got strange amc may have
made this song
again
uh the please was not always known as
gandalf what was his first name is it
ethrin luin
maira
melco
or baldorfin
i know miranda i know
i always thought he was called olarin so
i'm a little throne
john john john i love you mike come on
john's been crazy we can't hear you john
we can't hear a roddy thing
you're basically silent
oh he's going to say something
dorothy not bad that was uh a typo uh
john's already spelt it wrong it's not
bald or thin for the last one it's
bladdoffin
which may give you a clue to the correct
answer i don't know it made any miranda
what do you think
um
those names don't ring a bell for me so
let's let's go with that last one she's
going for blood or thin
it's the correct dancer
oh
john i can't believe you john honestly
these these questions are so difficult
um
i'm afraid um sarah we are going to have
to give you a very difficult one to
start with because uh miranda's already
had a difficult one and we have to keep
the level high but after this maybe we
could go back to some old questions that
we had because these are
very difficult well it's a difficult
quiz right
are you ready sarah i'm ready
what does gandalf mean an old norse
in the language of old norse what does
gandalf mean does it mean a
staff was it
b
great white
godfather
staff wizard
great white
staff elf
or godfather
do you speak old norse sarah i don't oh
you should say it's a lovely language
it's uh it's like music to your ears it
sounds like it would be
so i don't know off the top of my head
but i'm gonna guess we're leveling the
plan
the first one
which would be wizard's staff wizard
yes that's my guess that's my final
guess it's a very good guess because it
was staffed something sarah but it was
staff
yes
so that's one nothing
monk blanc
okay
question number three lovely miranda
this was brought to us by carl h in
benton
arkansas and and can you just can i just
say i read this one before we came on
and not only is it difficult i don't
even know what it means
yeah
well it's i i know what it means but do
you explain that to me well yeah would
you if you read it then former randy
yeah and then i'll and then you could
explain it for me question three miranda
here we go
who was going to be a hobbit named
trotter due to having wooden shoes from
a prior torture in mordor strange
strangely worded question to be fair
yeah what does that mean so this is what
i think it means and i'll give you the
the four part uh answers i think what
the
what the uh question is is
tolkien had a written originally written
this character as a hobbit right called
trotter the reason why it was called
trotter was because he was he had wooden
shoes that were given to him as a
torture device when he was in mordor so
they captured a hobbit and instead of
going around in bare feet right he said
no you will now wear wooden shoes and he
was walking around oh my god these clogs
are killing me
this character was originally gonna be a
hobbit called trotter how did it end up
becoming just the evolution of that
character so does that make does that
make sense miranda in terms of the
question
as much sense as it can i think
yeah hang on john
john was thinking about saying something
there now okay here's your four part
here's your four part um
four options for the answer
a
aragon son of aerothorn be
boring
son of denethol
c
theoden also son of byron oh no
that's the king
the steward
or d faramir son
you want those answers again
i know please this is a hard question
this makes no sense to me
centers by carol h benson in arkansas
and how did trump
really i'm not going to ruin it but how
did tolkien write a hobbit called
trotter john says it checks out on the
internet but everything checks out on
the internet you know you can find out
and then became either aragon me at thea
dinner farm here so the the the options
are aragorn boromir theodin or faramir
what do you think miranda i like this
hard quiz to be honest do you like it
i'm gonna i'm gonna guess theoden
miranda i'm sorry it's not the right
answer well this gives a chance for
sarah to get stealing you can steal it
here sir one we can make it one each
year but it's easier for sarah now
because now she has an option of three
instead of four oh are we gonna can you
jump in on someone else's question you
just said sarah could i i was gonna say
by her her next question oh no she can't
then so we'll just give him
we'll give you the end i'm sorry ladies
it's a bit of a hectic quiz but that's
part of the charm of it really miranda
john is now going to inform us and
educate us on the national anthem
johnny boy all right
so aragorn's character and story arc
underwent a series of development and
name changes before the version seeing
the lord of the rings as token did not
have the full plot of the story or its
background planned out the first germ of
the character later evolved into aragorn
or strider was a peculiar hobbit met by
bingo bolger baggins precursor to frodo
at the end of the prance and pony
now i seem to remember at some point in
new zealand someone telling me
do
do did you know that aragorn was at one
point gonna be a hobbit and then it got
changed i'd seem to remember that so
there's maybe dance ladies is aragorn
which is strange really it's an as this
is a very difficult question
what is one nil to the lovely miranda
because she got a question one yeah and
miranda's on my team but anyways sorry
that's true this is your chance
yeah we'll get them
now you need two answers to this one
because
at the time of the third age there are
five wizards in middle east
there are two blue wizards
are the blue wizards called
alatar
two of these guys are blue wizards
i think i'd get this due to a process of
elimination yeah i was gonna say process
of elimination it's not radical because
he's brown right sauron because he's
the bad guy he's white what's the first
two it's alatar and polando
and we're sitting at one all one one
nice this is actually getting quite
exciting
yes
this question number five brought to us
from cody l in
riverbank california but i think it's
just riverbank i would say
here we go miranda during the scene in
the extended version of the fellowship
of the ring the only version to watch
where the party meets haldier in
lothlorien what does gimli say to haldir
in elvish that makes aragorn scold him
does he say a
i admire you here
b
i'll spit on your grave
c
may you perish in quenya
or d
do you have any lambus
i'll give you those again miranda hey i
admire your hair if he did say that he's
been a businessman hold on oh hello
in the movie he did say these
these this this sentence in elvish
yeah it says in elvish in the question
in elvish
could you give us it in elvis oh it's uh
my elvish shirt it's not not great today
it's fallen off a cliff all right so
you're translating it to english
a i admire your hair
b i spit on your grave
c
may you perish in quenya
or d do you have any lambdas
i know
i know it's not easy these are hard
questions i will tell you miranda
stephen colbert wouldn't have got these
i will tell you that day on set when we
filmed this scene was one of the
funniest days what johnny's dave is
funny because johnny davis could not
remember this line remember yeah
and he just
lied oh god's sake
it was so funny and i can't remember it
in elvish but
in english it's one of them
um
all right it's gonna have to be another
guess for me but okay i'm gonna guess
the first one because i like the idea of
him being sassy like that
i admire your hair
it's not the no it's not the correct
chance
the correct answer unfortunately is i
spit on your grave which is quite
aggressive what a thing to see someone
you've just met yeah well i just don't
have graves so that's even more
insulting lovely bit of knowledge there
sarah we could give her a bonus point
because miranda's on my side
sorry you can get ahead here sarah if
you can answer this one correctly and
this one is actually from david smithen
who was a former contestant on this quiz
right here
now
who was legolases
father
was it tranduil
sylvan
falmari
or avari
that would be threandwill king of
merkwood
now hold on this is the last two
questions
this is tough yeah but these are both
really tough oh they're very tough
they've all been tough
so the holidays are almost upon us and
it's time to really lean in this year me
undies wants to help you bring comfort
home for the holidays and comfort is a
word dom because i tell you what they
are comfortable i've been trying out
these undies and they are fantastic and
for this cozy season they also have
onesies loungewear pajamas i tried the
onesie for the first time that's a comfy
thing i bet you look absolutely
fantastic with new classic played and
holiday sweater prints me on this is
turning up the comfort this holiday
season their undies loungewear and
sleepwear are made out of soft
breathable stretchy fabrics that are
ideal for getting cozy by the fire with
a lovely hot cup of cocoa may the whole
family smile with matching pj sets or
spoil your partner with plush robes and
slippers whatever you decide everyone
will be rolling into the new year comfy
than before available in sizes extra
small through to 4xl me undies has a
little something for everyone on your
list looking for more inspiration check
out their holiday gift guide for all
things cozy and comfy me undies has a
great offer for our listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 15 off and
free shipping right to your door your
days of fighting for your life in the
mall parking lot are over to get 50 off
your first order free shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
onion that's meondis.com
right tom what's easier than opening a
can of cranberry sauce i'll tell you
getting free life insurance quotes with
policy genius to properly provide for
the families most people need 10 times
the life insurance coverage that they
get through their employer
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why compare well you
could save 50 percent or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius you could save thirteen
hundred dollars or more per year on life
insurance by using policy juniors to
compare policies and eligible applicants
can get covered in as little as a week
thanks to an award-winning policy option
that swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call this
exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor higher than
options from ladder ethos and bestow
getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com
slash onion in minutes you can work out
how much life insurance coverage you
need and compare personalized quotes to
find your best price head to
policygenius.com
onion to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice to get it right
here we go miranda
but to be fair miranda both of these
questions are hard so it's not as if
you're getting a tough one and sarah's
going to be getting these ones so here
we go
and it's 2-1 let's do one
okay miranda what was the date that
frodo was last seen in the shire
i know and the shire well
oh no last seen in the world of lord of
the rings i guess
because yeah
what does this question mean john i'm
trying to make it hold on john is johnny
here's john to clear this one up on the
question it says just last scene last
scene last scene do you mean before it
went off to the great havens must have
been must have been yeah because the
last time we see the last time he is
seen is at the grey haven and we were
there see ya see you through
what was that day it was tough that is
definitely your options are
12
3001
september 29th
3021
february 3rd 2011
or of course july 21st
3022.
well that is not i mean who knows that
i don't even think stephen colbert would
know that i don't think even tolkien
would not i think it's made up by john
so it's either october september
february or july and it's either 3001
3021
11 or 22 if you know the years
well i know the fellowship set out in
3018. so it has to be after that very
very good tremendous number so you've
narrowed it down to two
and john just said there's a clue
somewhere johnny could chip in with a
clue on both of these if you want men
come easier okay
no okay you can't hear me so i don't
know if you want to give this clue
it would be
having to do with his birthday right i
lovely stuff you did that clue where are
you cold hello you have i've rubbing my
the hair in my hands yeah enjoy it felt
nice like a bigger hanging tan over
there it's lovely keeping warm um we
need your elven cloak i need something
so we gave miranda that clue
certainly so she's narrowed it to two
well you've narrowed it down to two well
maybe we don't really so
september 29th 3021
or july 21 30 22.
do you want a clue miranda i mean we
like you guys so we can give you a clue
if you want you can ask me for a quick
clue
i would love a clue
the clue is
the clue could be in
frodo's birthday
something
something if you know
frodo's birthday anyway and your two
options are september 29
21 or july 21 30 22.
so i believe photo's birthday is
september 22nd so i'm going to go with
this september 29th
date
is this
you took that question and you you
ripped apart all the layers yeah you
banked it in the ass you took away wrong
answers until all that was left was the
correct one so what's the scores now is
it two all the scores on the doors
is it not too gentle
are you keeping abreast of this two it's
two two two a piece sarah this to win it
this for all the marbles and there will
be a bag of marbles there will be you
will get i expect nothing less
fantastic i love marbles bill you know
now
this has got to do with your uh
knowledge of the geography of middle
east
what was the largest town
in the shire
was it a
green fields
b
russia bog
c
hobbiton
or d
michael delving
can you read those again here they come
again sarah i'm not sure of my
pronunciation on the fourth one perhaps
tom could help me when i get there
a green fields
b
rush bog
c
hobbiton and d
maybe michelle michelle delving would
they have a french michael delving i
think it's just michael delving
thank you very much stand corrected so
which one of those four would you say
was the largest town within the borders
of the shire
i think it's either hobbiton or michael
delving so we're taking out the other
two
and you can ask dom
for a hint yeah go on then oh god a clue
miranda got a clue in the last one i
don't i do no i don't yeah you no it's
true you should have a clue um i i mean
i i don't
because i didn't know the answer
i'm not sure do you know the answer
johnny may have a clue for you here
sarah maybe we should start calling john
johnny clue johnny clue cool green
fields russia
hobbiton john is delving into the
worldwide interwebs for a clue looking
for a clue
i would give you one but it's really
dom's just my clue to give now would you
say
that mary
would mary have been seen in this in the
film would you talk about mary the
magnificent mary the magnificent
not talking about the verse
only the movie
i don't think um
you don't think i don't think the
hobbits were seen was seen ah well
there's a closure there's a clue sarah
johnny claude we don't need a clue keep
your clues johnny there's your clue sir
i need your clues johnny i very much
suspect that none of the hobbits got
anywhere near to this area during in the
filming of in the films
sarah in the books i'm sure mary got
there because he was magnificent both
these ladies seem to have an incredible
knowledge of talking and this has been i
think i'm gonna go for it i'm gonna go
for michael delving
is the correct answer
oh sarah well played well played
fantastic did you see that thank you um
very well that was the hardest quit that
was more difficult than than we even
gave stephen colbert yeah and he got
stumped he professes to be an expert on
dern dingle which i think both these
ladies would have got dan dingle easily
now the rules uh
suggest that sarah can now ask billy and
i a question you could you could ask us
the same question or you could ask us
both an individual question if you
prefer sarah
right um i came up with a few um i'll
give you a choice would you like one
from the hobbit or the lord of the rings
the lord of the rings
the lord of the rings yes
great
so shout out to my brother for helping
me come up with this one what's his name
what's his name his name's nate thank
you they've asked that she might have
forgotten his name and then
that's very embarrassing
hi nate hi nate it's not nate diaz is it
no that would be cool that's terrifying
yeah absolutely
right so the question is during the
battle of helm's deep two characters
compete for the most orc kills who won
the contest and what was the final count
can we confer can billy and i confess
you can't confirm
dominic it's like listening it's
definitely legalizing him there during
the now during the battle of helm's deep
yeah you know at certain points one's
above the earth yeah yeah
and then at one point he's like um he
was already dead and he was like well i
i think certainly during the book and
maybe even during the film trilogy both
of them gain a lead so at helm's deep
mm-hmm
i would guess
oh gosh that's a tough one i was just
about to say i would guess legless is as
winning
isn't he isn't a draw and then gimli
puts his accent in one of them
goes
1918
well so you've got gimli
the
number is incorrect though so gimli
reports that his total is 43 and legolas
says 42 however it's a little
inconclusive because the orc does twitch
after legolas shoots it so so i've got
this story made in a tie yes it might
have ended in a tie ah good but the
number is 43 to 42 and actually
42 to 41. oh wow and 42 is an extremely
powerful mythological number and doesn't
it doesn't it show up in hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy well it's the answer
to the the
world the universe and everything isn't
it
life the universe and everything thank
you miranda shows up in my
life a lot the number 42. does it yeah
i love you 42 times 100.
thanks is that quite a lot i'm going to
this is kind of neither here nor their
story but i remember going to a kind of
a high-end butchers
years ago
and buying two cuts of meat right and
they were 21
each and remember saying to our friend
nigel 42
for two cuts of me and it became a joke
where if i was surprised by something he
would go 42. so that's why you're vegan
it's purely financial you know me i'm
thrifty you're very thri he's very
thrifty ladies that was a fantastic is
there another question or is that no
that's it that's the end of the quiz
that's the oh wait did you have all done
john's got something inside one question
did you want to ask the bonus question
to the other contestant if she gets it
right she can ask her question oh
let's see well hold on miranda there's a
die breaker question here miranda
oh
this makes no added so we'll do this to
keep it to keep it fun this is to see if
you can ask the question and if you
don't get it right your question just
disappears with you and we will never
hear it now if you want to help miranda
sarah i we don't mind the next official
quiz is over we will actually help you
because i want to hear your have you got
a question for us miranda
i do i don't i'd like to hear i was
going to say it doesn't need it can of
course be a question about lord of the
rings or whatever you want but it can
just be a question you can be like
what's your favorite cheese yeah
something like that anyway go on go on
bills right so this is what john's got
for you today
name three of the seven gates of
gondolin
here
yeah
sarah's face
and so basically
just give him no no i think how this
works is they've got to name three of
these seven yeah they're correct because
but they're all the seven ali yeah most
of the afternoon at least three yeah oh
god yeah so don't give them the options
i don't even know what the gates of
gondolin are there i know what are they
they're gates that allow you into the
city of gondor surrounding gondor so
there's the main gate and then you've
got other gates surrounding it i mean
this is an educated guess i'm not
entirely sure but that's my and all the
gates are called the gate of something
and you only have to name three miranda
and to give you a little clue
they
are all you know it's kind of like
materials give us one of them oh we'll
give you one as an example and then
you've got to get the other three so as
an example
one of the gates is called the gate of
gold
and then hit me you might have some
others that are similar you know
the gate of
and it's something other than gold and
there's another seven see if you can
give us three out of seven
bill doesn't okay
you guys are really trying to stunt me
today sorry miranda the gate of gold
gold always believe in your soul
um
i mean i'll guess the gate of silver
that's one okay
um stay in that mindset think about the
olympics
uh the gate of bronze is the correct
answer now you only need to go you only
need one more so just think of a
material that a gate might be possibly
made of
right yeah um
a gate of iron perhaps oh very good we
could give up
i mean
should we give him that because she's
never going to get the [ __ ] you'll never
get that bet but give us something else
what's going on what's your gate made of
at your house in a garden
gate a gate of wood
you did almost get it right uh miranda
it's the gate of rhythm iron but no
one's gonna work out that the iron has
been rhythmed and there's also the gate
of stone and the gate of steel
anyway miranda do you have a question
for for billy now you don't have to
i do i do actually so i know in a
previous episode uh you discussed the
three elven rings and how your good
friend gandalf is the bearer of one of
these rings yeah
so it's kind of a two-part question my
question is uh can you tell me which
ring
he is the bearer of and who gave him his
ring and i have multiple choice if you
would like that
dominic i think we will take the
multiple choice on this we should tell
them you know do you know the answer to
anything
not sure i know the name of it who gives
him it
doesn't
give him her i would think galadriel she
would like people let's get let's get
them she loves giving gifts that's a
gift
that's her love language yeah
uh
can you give us the
options miranda yeah just give us any
options of course
so
the names of the three rings are villia
[Laughter]
wait a minute give us them again please
i think
naria or nenya now i don't think it's
naria cause that sounds too much like
narnia i think it's the last one right
but and then what was the other thing
who gave it to him are there options for
who gave him it would you like those
options now as well yes please dave the
guy from the pub phillip the guy who
used to do his carpentry and galadriel
go on was it a keller born
b
glorified
c
kierdan
or d e
kelly brimbour oh
it wasn't glad you she was
holding an answer she's always hanging
about with kelebon so maybe she thought
i've given too much gifts to this
wizards over the years
do me a favor i've got this ring here
could you calibon that's like her kind
of mock husband yeah that kid again and
then glorious friendly yeah that's that
really powerful so it could be that
lives in both yeah at zones not zones
i don't know i don't know i definitely
think it's the third
name gnaria or something like that yeah
gorf and golovkin
should we say that yeah
okay so we think it's not the the name
of the ring is the third one
or something like that and the person
giving the ring is glorfindel yeah
that's what we think so you're correct
his ring is called naria it's the ring
of fire
but unfortunately it was not glorified
he was given the ring by kierdan the
oldest elf
left in middle earth he was jeremy
the oldest elf left he was senile he
used to say who is this
all right give it to this young man here
take this
one
and i don't like it anymore i'm not
going to heaven you'll need it
who would like this ring of fire that
one wasn't rig of ice next um
well thank you fantastic questions
fantastic contestants
oh thank you guys for having us we will
try so much
some way to get some sort of some type
of something
involving the french onion there must be
some sort of gift we're going to get
we're definitely going to do that for
both of you
and thank goodness we had real tolkien
um experts on because that was a hard
question very tough
thank you thank you very much thank you
ladies have a lovely rest of your day
bye-bye thanks for being on the show
hey guys so that was a difficult quiz i
like the difficulties you did like
difficult because the
playing field was leveled it was
difficult for everyone across the board
i kind of like it then it's easy
sometimes and sarah and miranda both
seem to like it because i think they
thought well this is more difficult than
i thought it was going to be but i do
have knowledge so it's not just like
i mean a couple of those questions i was
like what is this even about yeah so if
you have any trivia questions because we
will have more quizzes please send them
to the friendship onion at castmedia.com
lovely stuff now you were going to talk
about one of your favorite subjects
this is the thing tom i don't want to
bring it down here based level because
we were talking high level it
it's just a bodily electric chain it's
like sweat it's everybody pees right but
i've been peeing in the morning and
thinking to myself that is quite a
lengthy pee that is a long time so i
i've taken a taken in a stopwatch
and uh timing
how long my p is and in the morning my
morning p
is around
um
give or take
a minute 26.
that is long a minute and a half so i
thought i'm gonna google what a normal p
is and a normal p
is around 20 odd seconds wow give or
take 16 seconds right so even on the
long side it's still less than 40
seconds but
well a couple of things come up very
quickly here when you're sleeping at
night obviously you you're filling up
that
impressive bladder of yours exactly
sorry to tell you bills
but as you get older
you slow down
the actual thing it has something to do
with your prostate because i'm talking
about like if there's a stop in the p
i stop the stopwatch and i don't start
it again right as soon as there's a stop
in the flow so you're saying heavy flow
like a lightsaber like a laser firing
out and it'll go like like a horse
and it would go out for a minute and 26
minute 26 so then i thought i'm gonna
look at the longest ever p yeah
how long do you think this i bet you the
longest ever pee is crazy someone who's
like come out of a coma or surgery or
something like that i bet you so i'm
gonna say something outlandish like
four and a half minutes
am i
you can overcome do you think that's
what
like when you come over
for a piss
do you think three months in a couple
minutes
i don't know how coma's work if anyone's
in a coma currently and they want to let
us know so the first thing this sergeant
says is get him to the toilet he's going
to need a hell of a pen
waiver was that close though four and a
half minutes you were amazingly close
just under five minutes wow so
i've i've had this idea that i would
like to break records on this show yeah
and i'm gonna go for that one well i
never thought i'd say this
but i would love to see you have a piss
yeah well it's good it's impressive
because it's a lot it's the sound
that's the thing that's impressive yeah
because as i say as soon as there's a
break in the flow
the stopwatch is off
the other thing which is great and you
should try it at home gentlemen it's
much harder for a lady but you should
try at home if you can is
i will always tend to pee
a full pint now if you've got a pint
glass at home
you know yeah get your tommy tucker in
the position where it can go into a pint
glass and don't think because you will
think it this is going to overflow it's
going to flow it won't it won't float
and go right up to the pine top and then
it'll stop and for me that's obviously
because i get a little tickle in my
brain to say you should go pee when my
bladder has a pint in it and it is
textbook like there's about that much
left at the top and then i'd drink it
right now
but i'll tell you what that's giving me
let me think tom
when i go to your house it reminds me
not to have a guinness
do you have
do you have a certain pee
paint tumbler or is it just anyone that
comes to hand no because well i only
drink out of pint glasses because i like
to chug my water but it's glass so piss
will not cling to glass i've noticed so
all you need to do a little a little
scrub with you know you just do
soft dishes
you're fine you know the other thing you
told me in new zealand which i tried and
to be honest i wasn't overly impressed
but you were really into this you were
like next time you need a really big
piss
drink water while you're doing it it's
amazing i was like well how does that
work you're like well water's coming in
and water's going out it's like it's
like the uh the great year
you you're like peeing like a like a
cycle yeah you're making a whole segment
i tried it and it was all right not
really into it no
so i think we've covered the week in
piss well i think if i could just see
what i thought my longest p ever is
please
and i never whoa oh go go go go go
i didn't tame it right one but what i
did what
it was june master and commander
mastering commander were not the
fastness of guam i was in mexico mexico
and we'd spend the whole day filming on
the boat on a boat and they were in the
tank
so you had a german tank no like a tank
the boat was in a pretend tank
we weren't in the sea
so you couldn't pee off the side no i've
got another story for another place
so i'd been in there all day and when i
get into the dressing room i needed to
be so bad
and my wife was there
and i started peeing to the point
where it became like a surreal
dream really and she was saying
are you okay is that okay yeah are you
all right yeah and it felt like every
piece of fluid in me
was i felt like i was going to come out
there like a prune i think it can be
really quite dangerous to have i think
that long and i would have definitely
filled up at your paint tumbler
overflowed i do this thing often
when i'm out and about in bars or
restaurants if someone comes in after me
your rhino or as they say in the united
states urinal aha
where
when they adjust about when i hear the
little
tinkle
i start making
noises like
and then
as it's kind of halfway through i turn
to the person and say do you get lumps
or the other one that i like is do you
get crystals
and just let them go what what
i never
never
remember orlando you couldn't talk to
him while he was having to pee like
don't don't i can't go i can't go yeah
and then obviously we would always talk
to him well let's try that would be
um
the flip side of that coin is he wants
people to talk to him when he defecates
so he actually has someone who he
employs 24 hours a day
at his house with katy perry where when
he toddles up to the toilet for a number
two yeah someone just sits down some
sometimes reads david copperfield to him
that's bro he likes dickens he likes
earnest anyway
yeah because i think for orlando because
he's so clean and everything's so
sweet about him
he doesn't like it when no that stuff
okay
well we'll leave it leave it there we'll
get orlando on the show to talk about
his defecatory uh habits but i'm glad
that we're up to date with all of your
pee stuff
and it's probably time to eat the world
let's eat the world dom let's do it what
are we doing this week one of my
favorites i think hang on i've got notes
on this oh
it is it's sometime
wow here comes johnny boy johnny clues
hey johnny clues hey thanks johnny claus
looks good
here he is thanks now this is
some tam
as they call it in i've moved away from
the mic there for a second
in thailand
or
papaya salad as we know it thank you
very much john that's terribly canned
i've had some of the most amazing times
eating papaya salad because
papaya salad is one of them things that
is very common all over thailand you
know exactly what you're going to get
doesn't tend to change
that much vegetarian unless you get a
bit of fish sauce in it which sometimes
we will put
fish sauce in it and it is fantastic and
we
hopefully
john asked for a spicy papaya no
where would you say is the first time
you tried this dum first time i had
papaya salad
probably in new zealand i think wow
because you had one of the best thai
restaurants in wellington at the bottom
of your street that is true yeah can't
you remember the name of that place hold
on you wouldn't and if we were tired and
we're just that one we would just get
some food from there we were we were all
addicted to tom yum soup oh and we've
got it from there
it was a great restaurant we went we
went to that place probably 50 times oh
i forget the name no that's terrible
i'll remember to i forget as well anyway
um we'll give you some info here guys
before we try it
papaya salad or some tam as it's called
in thailand often combines a combination
of shredded young
green papaya because obviously uh you
know it gets ripe and turns a different
color so when it's green it's young
thai chilies green beans cherry tomatoes
sometimes dried baby shrimp or prawns
carrots green beans roasted peanuts in a
tangy lime sauce with sometimes a little
bit of
fish sauce
yep the great thing about thailand is
and you'll get this on your tables in
thailand and all over southeast asia
is you always have a little bit of salt
a little bit of sugar a little bit of
heat
a little bit of tangy fish sauce so
whatever you get you can you can create
your own kind of water yeah that's what
it says here it shows me
it's basically similar combinations of
these papaya salad ingredients although
some street market vendors will add
extra palm sugar to lessen the kick of
the chilies or even fermented fish to
give it that pungent twist
but beyond those variation the most
important factors are the crunchy
texture of the unripe papaya and the
combination of the different taste
sensations i think that's what you like
yeah i love it it's all kind of awesome
everything on top of each other yeah
yeah i love the sweet salty tangy sour
all on top and the lime juice is amazing
we've spent quite a bit of time in
thailand and one of the things that we
know about that part of the world is
it's generally roasting hot you're
losing a lot of your salts and your
minerals and i think the great thing
about papaya salad is you're getting a
lot of excuse me a lot of it back
because it's a combination of a few
things and it's so refreshing shall we
eat it should we try it yeah come on
also as we're trying it i'll read a
little thing here that says well papaya
salad is a signature dish in cambodia
lao and vietnam it's the thai version
that's become the most famous however
most food historians believe that this
dish actually originated in lao
which is a part of the world that i've
been to next door to thailand and
unfortunately lao
had more bombs dropped on it in the
vietnam war than vietnam
crazy not
crazy get in your mouth oh god is it hot
is it spicy
you know
lovely lovely
smells good
oh yeah smells great would you say that
spicy meals there's a little spicy it's
not crazy
but
it's a lovely flavor dom
it's got nuts in it
um
you have a lot of people saying please
don't chew too closely mike
i have a lot of people saying can you
make sure that you're too close to the
mic
you know there's people who've called
something
yeah there's people out there on twitch
and on
youtube and stuff
usually attractive men or women yeah
and they
charge people
to just eat stuff very close to them
yeah that's me in a chocolate bar today
well i got spicy about that
now where's the papaya
this is the papaya crazy horse this was
it the white stuff the the the young
papaya is that the papaya those chilies
they love his noodles
you're crazy those chilies they're
little tiny chillies
green ones they are called in thailand
rat [ __ ] chilis
because they resemble
rat [ __ ] well that's ashima which is
number rat [ __ ] is usually about the
shape of a of a maggot
like the greatest conversation to have
while you're eating
um
very hot very spicy
um and nut storm nuts
i love when you get asian food
with nuts in it
not always will make something better
there's peanuts in these yeah what have
we learned about peanuts
peanuts the jungle fresh
yeah but then
what aren't what aren't peanuts ah
peanuts aren't and not no they're a
legume
they're more closely related to a bean
than a knot i actually learnt that in
the friendship on you
from
stephen colbert yeah
oh
hang on i got a little bit of it up my
nose there don't worry i'll go
the great thing about bar salad is
generally vegetarian unless you unless
you're putting fish sauce in there and
also
if you like it which a lot of people do
you can find it everywhere around
southeast asia so if you're struggling
you don't know what to eat on the menu
you don't recognize anything on the menu
you can always say sometime and they'll
have it and then when you're finished
eating your sometime
you can say aroi ma which means very
tasty
oh or um
which means thank you thank you and we
had
a lady from thailand on load their rings
didn't we yeah fun who is mainly my um
scale double
we we use scale doubles for people who
don't know
they use lots of things to to show the
difference in height between hobbits and
men and elves
and one of the things we did was we had
scale doubles so we had um
some people from india and thailand
and others um
who are um smaller
who in uh in a wide shot if there was
legolas and aragorn and the four hobbits
and we could use the scale doubles and
they were brilliant and so helpful and
and and doing those shots and phone was
so wonderful and lovely and
um
she was just such such a such a joy to
have on set she was your scale double
more than anything else wasn't it yeah
and she tried to teach me some thai but
i was really bad at it yeah
um so eddie cap hello
mm-hmm
i remember fun's full name was
chan santor brabrahan mm-hmm
let's read a few a few more things about
about salad in the lao isan district
somtam which is papaya salad was
originally called
the bakung part translates to mean
papaya while tam means pounded
since making green papaya salad involves
a lot of pestle and malta action it
makes sense that this is once known as
pounded papaya and that's the
interesting thing if you watch it being
made fresh
so that the person will have a pestle
and mortar
yeah stick the young papaya in there
first and then they'll put all the raw
ingredients in there
and they'll just try and break
everything apart and then very often in
thailand
they'll put it in a little see-through
bag for you
you get like a fork and then when it's
done this is what i used to you get the
whole bag
take the nozzle put it all in your mouth
and then just invert it
you drink all the juice that's my
favorite part but i sold the juice i got
really hot bit there really chilly
really hot but you like spicy food
actually that uh just
actually painful
it's good
do you want to read the last fact
because we've got one more fact here
here is the last fact that i know
about papaya salad the name change came
as a result of mass migration from the
isan region to bangkok migrant workers
shared their love of the papaya salad
they grew up eating with both the recipe
and the name changing over time
for some time to become the street
market staple as today although the
pounded part of the dish's name has
remained as sometime translates to
pounded sour
this is my favorite part of the dish
hang on
it made me want to do that
i would i would describe that taste as
pungent what's all the liquid is that
from the papaya
yeah lime juice
no i don't think there's not much papaya
juice in there lime juice
um maybe a little bit of lemon juice
maybe they might put in there quite
sweet that yeah good i could have gone
hotter i like chilled oh yeah i could
have gone because you can get
thai hot or you can get
american heart and i would have said
thai hot i like i like food
spicy food that
completely
wakes up my digestive system
we had a barbecue at your house last
week and you cooked some
hot peppers on the barbecue yeah it's
your favorite what are those
they only come out at this time of year
um they're like a big shishito yeah what
are they called now big a lot of the um
uh mexican restaurants will have them
now and south american they're called
something and i think they only come out
at this time of year but i got them
didn't i and i stuck them on the grill a
little bit of olive oil a little bit of
salt that's all i did and i thought
maybe we'll have half of these one of
these each you have about three of them
yeah i love them and i'm talking they're
about eight inches long yeah they're
whoppers and uh
god you you enjoyed them i love them and
we watched yours didn't we
yeah we watched jaws
i've been i've been avoiding showing my
son jaws because he's loving surfing and
being in the water and i remember when i
saw jaws it really put me off being
underwater it wasn't as scary as i
remember no it's a great film brilliant
brilliant
script brilliant acting
but
i think we've become desensitized to
scary stuff now because when i was a kid
and i watched jersey it was terrifying
and i was just like well yeah i could
see a couple of scary moments but not
really yeah great film though brilliant
right well should we give this some
scores please dumb
flavor
for me
like i said i'd like it to be a little
bit hotter but i'm not going to critique
it too much so the flavor
is a 9.4 yeah almost perfect it's a
great flavor and
as it was talking about how it mixes all
the flavors that's what makes it so
special i'm going to give that a bang on
nine okay
um
aesthetics mine's all gone but
it's a bit
i mean
i wouldn't say it's the most
pleasing
on the eye salad there's other salads
that look a little bit more
you know presented
this is like a bit of a smashed up
messed up type thing
nice colors though
but yeah it's not
the most pleasing on the i'm gonna give
it a i'm gonna give it a
6.5 yeah i hear you dom there's a lot of
other
uh
thai dishes and dishes from that sort of
part of the world that are very
beautiful yeah so i'll i'll knock it
down because of that and i'll give it a
7.2 oh nice okay
usefulness
is it useful
i mean
they do give it you in a bag in thailand
so you can kind of carry it around
but it's a bit finicky to eat i mean
it's a bit sticky on my hands now if
it's in the fridge do you say
oh it's okay we've got papaya salad in
there so i'll be able to make uh
something you wouldn't make a you
wouldn't put it in a roaster oh i'm
going to make a pie with it next day
one of the few things that i will say
one of the things that i'll say about it
is because it's kind of preserved ish in
a little citrus juice it does
have a bit of a shelf life okay not
super long but if you've got a lot of it
the next day it's fine the day after
that's fine and then probably day four
or five you probably wouldn't be
throwing it out but you know like a lot
of salads that you get from a place the
day after it's starting to wilt yeah
so there's that so that does make it if
you think to yourself i'm going to be in
the house for four days yeah i'll buy
too much of something and that will keep
me going yeah while i'm writing this
script right right for tom cruise right
right then that would be in the fridge
and you think well i could get i could
get that whenever i need it yeah so
yeah
i'm going to say i'm going to give it a
3.5 for usefulness well that's not very
useful no it's not that
useful that's a salad 4.5 okay nice
beautiful well that's the highest salad
was papaya salad
um absolutely delicious and i love it
with nuts and it's not enough
but i love it with nuts
i think we've run out of time bills have
we already well we had a very long
very in-depth quiz oh yeah that was
quite difficult i'm going to go to bed
thinking about that
so
we'll see you guys next week but before
we go if you want to get in touch with
us remember you can send us a voice note
or voice message
at speakpipe.com
forward slash that friendship
and you can always send us an email at
the friendship onion.com
fast forward no no it can't be flash
forward no no the friendship onion at
cass media dot com let's cast with a k
if you want to
uh
rate review and subscribe to the
friendship onion we would appreciate it
it really helps us out and if you write
a great review there's a chance that we
might put it up on our social media
channels or include it in the show we
also have a spotify channel which is the
friendship onion be aware there's a lot
more music people out there pretending
to be us but anytime we have a funky
song which we've run out of time for
this week we put it up on our spotify
channel
and we will see you guys
week
on the friendship onion goodbye bye
[Music]